I have to wait a min on this right away
you have lost an incredible amount of
blades 75 pounds
all told yeah yeah thank you thank you
how did you how did you do this
I borrowed Chris Christie's laughing
okay no I felt bad about it because I
didn't think he was done with it you
know way to reach your goal and they get
up to know I like your laughing no I
know I said it's an operation but I
actually I the the true story is working
on Eagle heart last summer I chipped my
front tooth on some pudding and I think
I took a shot of it I took a selfie why
would I look like okay and I had to go
to a dentist out here and I went to like
this Hollywood dentist who he was kind
of slick he was sort of like Rob Lowe
from that Liberace movie and and he kind
of and he talked me into capping all my
teeth and you know and I figured okay
he's out in LA he knows you know how to
do this and and he brought out a big
book and you pick what you like and I
picked you know the Clark Gable the
Chloe's yeah that's what you can do and
but this is what he gave me let me show
you what he get that's what he did
I know well no apparently that was the
Gary Busey
gable at all but the problem was those
didn't fit really well and I couldn't
chew solid food so I lost like 20 pounds
working on Eagleheart and then back east
I just started running and and I'm
addicted to running I'm up to like 35
miles a day oh my god
so you're recommending as a diet never
heard get your teeth capped on a
comfortable absolutely dead yak get get
bad fake teeth do you feel good do you
dis all my gosh I feel great I mean I I
feel like a new man not all of me feels
great my stomach feels depressed
bustling really what do mean it feels
different
and it looks too pristine um do you know
what a paniculata chyme pronouncing that
right that's when you're you have a lot
of weight and you lose it quickly and
then your skin doesn't tighten up it
kind of sags down and and that's what's
happened to me can I stand up here I
don't know we haven't rehearsed this at
all yeah okay let me just see this
there's a lot of weight quickly and then
alright so look at that like that's it's
like like that it's it's not what it's
supposed to look like yeah that's right
do you have a sharp e sharp it yeah cuz
it just looks it looks really sad it
just looks like you know if you put like
an eye there
[Laughter]
[Applause]
he's really fun
and he kind of talked sad - he's just
like
ah I'm so depressed
I've got a cigarette Andy there you go
[Applause]
smoking gear
I'll tell meds no so great yeah I got a
drink Lisa right because it's depression
he's in a bad shape your stomach he's
also a degenerate gambler
[Applause]
two times a day he's not even enjoying
we're here look at table it's not even
enjoy how he's smiling
take a look
[Applause]
does it know I'm talking about me oh you